bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale la
leçon sicilienne nash d'abord le coup
six f4 avec pour présenter cette
émission
stéphane laborde qui nous fait l'honneur
de porter la barbe en ce moment bonjour
stéphane ayouaz loi je laisse pousser un
peu d'abord c'est pour acquérir plus de
sagesse et jouer les positions avec plus
de deux temps tranquillement quoi tout
en sérénité donc la sicile ndash dorff
on en a déjà parlé il ya eu beaucoup
d'émissions qui ont été consacrés c'est
une arme violente pour le gain et en
jouant cette option avec six f4 et bien
le joueur qui allait blanc tente de vous
compterez est d'amener la position sur
un terrain équilibré en fait ils jouent
pour la nuit là ne vous pour la nulle
intention il faut aussi jouer pour le
guen si on fait pas attention il va
falloir réagir justement de façon
appropriée exactement alors des très
fort joueur on employer cette arme avec
six f4 c'est le choix par exemple de
peter l'écho qu'ils aient joué ça
pendant très longtemps également andré
sokolov parmi les forts joueurs joseph k
la guerre ont tout un tas de très forts
grands maîtres ont choisi cette arme
avec six f4 alors tout de suite nous
allons passer en pastilles pour vous
montrer la position
c'est parti la fameuses pastilles à la
pastille donc sicilienne donc ces scènes
qu on rappelle stéphane que le thème de
l'émission c'est qu'on a les noirs qu'on
veut jouer la cécilienne âge d'or ouais
et donc on veut avoir une solution
adaptée pour jouer contre ce coup ci
c'est 4 donc on détaille pas les options
des noirs mais seulement celle des
blancs ou tout à fait
khalef trois des six normales des 4 tu
en prends des quatre ans reprend du
cavalier on attaque le pion central
développement du canadien ces trois tout
ça et on l'a déjà vu plusieurs fois à 6
on rentre d'un fameuse d'un âge d'or la
night of et là c'est là que nous avons
déjà traité beaucoup d'options notamment
la sortie du four henri iii qu'est la
plus dangereuse et qui est dangereuse la
sortie du fonds au ccap la sortie du
fond de nous avons traité ces trois
coups il reste donc le coup j'ai ça on
verra plus tard
et également le coup f4 c'est celui
qu'on regarde aujourd'hui six f4
stéphane c'est un point qui on peut le
dire néglige la sortie des pièces donc a
priori pas forcément alors dans un
premier temps ça bouge un peu la sortie
du fou c'est un service vous cmn a du
mal à sortir
puisque s'ils viennent sur la case de
trois maintenant sur cavani g4 on n'a
pas la possibilité de jouer donc fou
angers 5 donc déboucher par le pion f4
par contre ça instaure le contrôle de la
case e 5
tout à fait f4 ça installe tout de suite
le duo de pions donc ça peut préparer
des f-5 ça peut préparer de5 ça prépare
beaucoup de choses
la contrepartie directe de ce coûteux de
pions c'est on le verra dans beaucoup
beaucoup de variantes cette diagonale là
qui commence à s'agrandir et qui est
donc affaibli puisqu'elle question f2
ouais on rappelle tarrach a dit le clos
fo on avance toujours trop tôt donc il
ya énormément thème basé sur cette
vieille conne donc notamment quand on
aura rouquet avec les blancs et bien le
ku'damm b61 store aura soit un clouage
du câble et des quatre soit avoir un
échec voire un échec et éventuellement
la taille du cube et 2 voilà donc les
inconvénients a priori de ce coup ci ce
f4 la réaction des noirs il faut pas
jouer avec le 6 parce que jouer avec le
6 c'est un peu petit bras dans cette
position table ça rame dans le pied dans
le plan des blancs pour jouer f5
exactement et en plus ce n'est pas
adapté puisque on ne chasse pas le
premier décathlon qu'on n'essaie pas
d'exploiter la diagonale donc premier
1er premier indice pour vous rappeler
qu'il faut jouer et bien on commence par
chasser le cavalier des quatre pour
pouvoir profiter de cette grande
diagonale noir qui est ouverte de faire
le petit rock des blancs donc on répond
tout de suite violemment vers le centre
vers le centre en jouant le coup au 7e 5
premiers
première chose surprenante 5 on n'a pas
peur on reprend du pillon et quand le
cavaly bouge
en échange les dames et ces 30 in c'est
tout à fait tranquille d'autant plus que
les blancs sont rassemblement objet de
pointe du roi pour ne pas perdre le pion
aux 4 donc ça pas de problème il faut
que les blancs bougent leur qui m'a dit
ils vont donc sur la case f3 case
extrêmement logique puisque maintenant
de dire qu'ils attaquent ce option oui
menace surprenant 5e nation prendre cinq
autres choses et bien si on prend en f4
et bien tout de suite il y à [ __ ] en
f4 avec un très bon développement des
pièces par un gain de temps un tempo
bien de temps et que ça me dirait notre
ami d'ami relève ainsi qu avec tempo
avec tempo
on joue donc à la libé destatis on
défend cureau 5 tout simplement
en attendant de voir comment les blancs
vont se développer alors les blancs dans
cette position eh bien il pourrait
sortir leur fou pour shooter rock mais
ils ont très peur du coup b5
oui parce que sur fous ces 4 par exemple
b5 suivi éventuellement de b4 par le
piano 4 tout à fait alors ça c'est
thématiques mais b5 suivi également de
fougue et cette ouais si on est pas si
on veut pas jouer bep cap qui est comme
un coup complexe dont on n'a pas sorti
trop pièce n'a pas envie de jouer b5 bi
4 pour prendre le plus de 4 donc b5 suis
trouvée c'est tout simplement va
contrôler la casse des cinq classes très
importante attaque et le quai henri iv
donc il a pas envie qu'on tombait 5
c'est normal donc les banques jouent
généralement à cap dans cette position
plus chaudes les cinq bons jeux donc fou
aux sept développement et ici il y a
deux variantes possibles pour les blancs
la moins dangereuse étant la première
qu'on va vous montrer c'est le coup
choisi par peter l'écho dans cette
partie c'est fou ces 4 on verra tout à
l'heure que la plus dangereuse c'est de
mettre le foin en d3 pour bien protéger
alors il ya peut-être une autre option
qui est serait de jouer à 5 ans pêcheur
b5 et compte 30 d'un v6 dans toutes les
variantes
c'est vrai mais c'était fans il faut pas
oublier que à 5 et une perte de temps et
ça serait un pion faible ça serait
éventuellement un pion fable est donc
sûre à 5 ans je dois tout simplement
petit robe dans un premier temps ensuite
on irait prendre en f4 et jouer cavalier
5 très vite et lancera le fou s'est vite
moi là nous avons un développement de
pièces tout à fait normal et ce pion à
saintes finalement sera en prise way
sera faible il faudra que la tour est là
pour le protéger tout à fait donc à 5
n'est pas vraiment un fou qui doit vous
faire peur ou ses quatre tentatives de
picard l'écho c'est quand même du
sérieux le fou vient naturellement sur
cette grande diagonale à ta question fc
ce qui semble logique puisque les noirs
ayant joué une scène qui n'ont pas eu 6
oui cette diagonale et semi ouverte on
va dire kazim pour le fou exactement en
plus avec petit rock on aura une tour en
f1 on voit que cette colonne ne demande
qu'à s'ouvrir
ouais on a aussi des cavaliers g5 qui
traîne bref on peut mettre la pression
sur ceux qui ont acheté donc vous ces
cartes est un coût tout à fait logique
garry kasparov réagi de façon très
dynamique et jude damas cinq dames à
cinq premières menaces cavaliers pension
aux quatre oui puisque le cas les c3
écrit il est cloué qu'est ce qu'on a
envie de faire ici ce n'est pas mon
envie de rock il met un petit rock ça
enlève le clouage petit repos relève le
clouage mais inconvénient majeur de
petits rock
stéphane c'est que ce atteindrait une
pièce il ya un piège et un piège après
petit rock le roi se retrouvent à angers
1 et donc on joue d'un à cinq ans et
cinq échecs au roi cette fameuse
rengaine il faut parer les chèques et
dames francesca et d'un procès quatre
hamas le fou donc ici on ne peut pas
jouer petit rock c'est un premier thème
avec cette diagonale dont des fractures
4 comme on peut dabo deux dames eu de
preuve alors 5 août dame contrecoup d'un
finalement un coude dames contre un coup
d'arrêt mais la dame à 5 peut-être plus
actif que la dame aux yeux de tous une
case clé pour les noirs c'est la case
aux cinq dans cette position va tout de
suite voir pourquoi donc la catastrophe
tout petit rock petit rock et maintenant
ils ajoutent que promettre 4 quand même
quand même donc les blancs naturellement
je vous fous pour un f4 et maintenant
comme la dame étant à cinq on peut jouer
le cavalier aux cinq voix là puisque
sinon quand la salle là mais terme des
huit c'était pas possible puisqu'il ya
deux pièces blanches qui contrôle le 5
donc ici maintenant on voit il ya de
défense
l'option des 6es la dame à saint qui
défendent le k5 donc pas de problème
quel est l'intérêt de ce week-end des 5
et bien tout simplement stéphane se
déplie les pièces non mais ça va pouvoir
sortir ça libère le fou s'est vite et
puis le cabillaud cinq attaques le pouce
et 4 déjà oui donc sa menace
éventuellement des gagnants fou donc on
va revoir les quelques coups
ses dents et eu tout simplement petit
rock des noirs après damas un petit rock
ici on est devant l'obligation je dirais
de prendre un f4 il faut le faire pour
pouvoir sortir nos pièces donc c'est
exactement ce qui se passe on joue
shampoing f4 fou pour un f4 kallio 5
pour sortir les pièces c'est vraiment
une manoeuvre de développement après
cabrio 5,6 les blancs bouge le fou une
façon normale par exemple en four b3 et
bien beaucoup d'options on peut jouer
fou j'ai quatre fous du kansas et une
première option qui coule cavaliers faut
aussi peut-être fou aussi ce qui est
intéressant également mais a priori on
jouera quand même fou g4 donc ici peter
l'écho tente le coup cavaliers des 5
alors c'est intéressant ce coup parce
que ça va fort sa force la réponse des
noirs cd toujours des coups assez
intéressant quand ça limite les
opportunités adverses puisque là il ya
une double menace ses cavaliers prendre
un set avec l'échec ganfoud et la
deuxième menace c'est de prendre le 5
avec le cavalier gagner en option tout à
fait donc surtout qui va les prendre
cette une menace totalement inadmissible
faut donc éliminer ce qui valide et
simple qui est très très fair qu'elle
prend des cinq fours en d5 important de
prendre du fou puisque le foot attaqué
par le cavalier et en plus si on avait
pris du poids on aurait bouché la démo
neil du fou exactement
il faut toujours content du fouet en
plus effectivement c'est cette colonne
des qui est quand même qui tape sur le
plan des six on n'a pas envie de la
bouche est fou aux six sorties de pièces
tout à fait classique normal tranquille
quelle est l'idée de ce fou fou au cices
et bien c'est de jouer c'était pas de
grands desseins cas là on arrive dans
une structure de sicilienne tout à fait
classique une structure de cécilienne
chef d'un gang comme on l'a déjà vu et
dès qu'on arrive justement sortir toutes
nos pièces et bien il n'y a pas de
problème d'autant plus qu'il ya toujours
dans le vent se démener six échecs
ouais j'suis dame prend b2 d'un promet
de pas forcément bon tout le temps
puisque derrière l'option b cette
emprise
ouais en tout cas ça traîne moi c'est à
dire qu'on pourrait jouer une tour sur
la dame
la dame bougé après tout reprend 17
exactement fou aux six dans cette
position le seul problème que pourrait
avoir les noirs cécile et blanc prenez
et 11,6 et ans le 5 et que les noirs
soient obligés de reprendre avec les
pions à chaque fois ça donnerait des
pions doublé
donc faibles donc ici il ya deux
possibilités soit on joue cavalier
prendre cinq options qui n'est pas
choisie par karl échos michael pendant
cinq soirs tout simplement a pu en
prendre 5 je pense peut-être comprend un
sac peut-être également fou prend des
seringues des 5es des pions prono 5
effectivement je prends le 5 / fou prend
aussi ce maintenant on ne prend pas
évidemment ici et on prendra un f4 nom
prend en f4 c'est ma plus fort
continuent d'attaquer le fou si son
attaque le fou maintenant le fou va
trouver une très belle diagonale ans m6
puis éventuellement se placer sur la
case aux 5
ici pas de problème donc ça c'est
important à voir ce qu après filles
aussi lisse maintenant fou prend aussi
c'est le choix de picardie qu on ne joue
pas pu en prendre aussi stéphane pour
éviter ces fabuleux en double et en
double échec intermédiaires qui valait
pour un f3 d'abord à cheikh est après
dame prend puis on prend 2,6 donc
maintenant effectivement les noirs une
structure de pions légèrement moins
bonne que les blancs moi c'est celle ci
font ça se défend il ya trois îlots et
trois îlots il veut dire trois îlots de
pions des deux côtés seulement quand
même les pions et 6 des six sont assez
faibles mais ce qu'il faut voir c'est
l'activité des noirs avec une tour forte
un fou qui menacent de venir en aide si
ce biais ronald forte qu'anticipée de
l'activité dernière chose à voir dans
cette partie c'est la suite forcé dame b
trois attaques de pions attaque bessette
et aux six des sept m6 hélas la défense
dams et cinq échecs rouach un dame s'est
vite et même ses villas d'un protège des
deux pions tout à fait et là on voit que
les coûts les noirs ont simplement joué
des m17 ou des coups comme ça des coups
solides de coûts encore tour a des seins
et b5
le coût final de garry kasparov après ça
il a une activité largement suffisante
pour compenser donc cette partie tuteurs
légaux garry kasparov s'est achevée par
une nulle rapide
voilà ça c'était donc la première partie
on va passer à la suivante qui une
partie gala guerre entre vosges qui
évite grand maître
totalement polonais totalement polonais
et gala guerre lui c'est c'est un axe
anglais suisses one c'est ça mais on lui
il a gagné le championnat d'angleterre
innocent oui les anglais mais il est
aussi suisse oui double donc il peut
gagner les deux championnats
exactement je prends donc tout ça fait
des coupes on vous a déjà commenté on
les passe donc rapidement 24,5 kf3
quelle idée c'est toujours un crac pour
empêcher des cinq fois aux 7
vous êtes fous des trois fournées 3 donc
la sas et peuvent tous ces cas là on
change exactement on change tout de
suite on défend bien le pion au capital
et kobe choisi fond ces quatre là c'est
fou d'être un petit rock normale petit
rock petit rock & cie très important on
prend en f4 alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
et bien qu'ils ont profité c'est normal
mais là on a plus la dame 1 à 5 pour
pour jouer cavalier de cinq exactement
mais par contre en revanche
eh bien il ya une grosse différence
majeure c'est qu'après fou pour un f4
on verra que ce n'est pas le principal
locaux principal ces rachats il y à dame
b 6 échecs
ouais mais oui toujours on s'était pas
de cette fameuse grande diagonale qui
est vraiment thématiques
madame b 6 et on voit que le cube et de
huit entreprises ont récemment les
blancs l'ont prévu c'est un salon oblige
c'est effectivement un sacrifice qui
peut s'avérer dangereux mais qui ne
l'est pas réellement roux a h1n1 prend
b2 alors intéressant parce que ce coût
d'un premier but en plus à table qu'à
laisser trois donc tempo exactement
comme dirait d'amiens comme dirait
d'avenir l'homme assis avec tempo
qu'elle est les dessins je dis ça parce
qu'ils haïssent a souvent dans les
commentaires
cavalier france calle des 5
ouais normal puis on prend des saints
qui là nous arrivons sur la pression
critiques de ses fils deux pions d'où
l'on voit ici que le fou détroit est un
bon coup puisque maintenant ce fou à une
très belle diagonale qui pointe noire le
roi adverse a noté stéphane que le fonds
prend la tête ou qui seraient thématique
n'est pas possible dans cette petite
ville malheureusement ça marche pas
puisque le fawcett contrôler la 4g 5
ouais en plus au noir de jouer ça c'est
vrai que c'est parce qu'en fait on fait
souvent faut expliquer pourquoi on fait
souvent fou prend hct fec foyer roi
prend et ensuite cavalier j 5 échecs
suivi de en général d'un mach 5 mg kg 4
en fonction de l'endroit où elle est le
le roi avec une grosse attaque mais là
c'est pas possible puisque sur calais g5
échec qu'on ferait tout simplement
cavaliers y aurait pu d'attac exactement
dans cette position les noix en
plusieurs options
il y a d'un b sides mb deux ans b 6 mais
ça ça va contre les principes parce
qu'en principe stéphane quand on a une
dame avancé dans le coin et demi et
qu'on a pris du matériel avec il faut la
laisser là pour pour faire diversion
faut la laisser là pour faire diversion
exactement puisque les blancs ont
tendance à perdre du temps pour l'achat
c'est donc à elle pas si mal placé et le
contrôle une belle diagonale quand même
l'un exactement le des gones a levé 2 g7
dans le roi qui défendent qui défend le
roi et puis bon elle fait un peu
pression sur le camp sous le gant blanc
un principe une fois de plus puisque
c'est quand même le thème de la leçon
est bien quand vous avez un point de
plus et changer les pièces évidemment
moins il ya de pièces - yade attaque
donc moyens de compensation pour
l'option sacrifier donc cavalier c5 en
plus on n'élimine pas n'importe quelle
pièce puisque on élimine se fout des
trois qui étaient quand même un fou
méchant oui alors double intérêt sukuk
halal c'est 5 1 ça permet d'envisager un
échange de pièces et deux ça libère le
fou s'est vite et ça permet d'envisager
un autre échange de pièces puisqu'on
peut envisager sous g4 pour échanger
lecavalier cette rencontre le cavaliere
3 tout simplement une fois qu'on a
changé toutes les pièces et bien on va
tout simplement gagner la partie avec un
point de plus ça se voit régulièrement
donc ici cette menace tout g4 est très
pénible donc à la guerre pour l'éviter
genou damien dame un attaquant le fou
hausse est donc encore une fois avec
tempo avec un poids tacle fawcett veut
remettre la dame sur laquelle j'ai 3
d'où elle attaquera le pion des six ânes
avec un fou et éventuellement créer des
menaces sur le roi crée des menaces
eurent droit donc ici cavale et prend
des trois on ne craint pas d'un procès
de stéphane puisqu'il ya encore le
fauteuil wild 15.4 qui narre une pièce
tu en prends des trois normales alors là
les pions blancs ils ont l'air ils ont
l'air vraiment un piteux état
tout à fait mais les noirs ou un
problème qu'il faut résoudre c'est le
faut cette attaque et le chant des six
aussi - et ses reflets f6 le retrait à
[ __ ] en d6 est justement stéphane pas
tout à fait puisqu'il faut aussi ce que
réussissent quand même qui menace d'un
prend pour un échange enfin gagné en
qualité
ouais qualité on le rappelle c'est un
faux point une tour dames 4 défense
maintenant ça devient très dangereux de
jouer d'un prend encore 1 puisque après
tout reprend fou prend si on prend là
la tour reprend et le fond reprend bien
le fou n'est plus en défense il peut y
avoir des g5 qui arrive voire même des
fous prend des six mois il y aurait
quand même une grosse attaque sur le roi
il ya du jeu c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
a envie dans cette position il faut
sortir les pièces on peut prendre deux
tours pour la dame mais ça dépend la
position oui dans l'état comme les piles
et noir sont quand même pas très bien
développé il reste encore le fossé 8 et
la torah 8 qui cherchent à savoir où ils
vont se placer il ya eu les blancs
peuvent monter une attaque développement
est très important donc ici on se fout
des sept en tout cas c'est josh kerr x
qui joue faux 17 qui est un grand
spécialiste la neige d'or avec l'idée
évidemment de mettre les tours une tour
sur la colonne peut on ne sait pas
encore laquelle
inopérant le pion des six il leur donne
c'est possible pour les blancs de le
prendre
et d'ailleurs ils vont le prendre mais
pas tout de suite a tout de suite tombé
un abord tourbe est un nain d'abattoirs
attaques nocturnes à calais avec tempo
là ils font tout reprend b cette attaque
le fou 17
à noter comme à troyes la dame protège
le rival à la dame est venue protéger le
plan des six pour combler cette
maintenant tour vite la partie a encore
continué de toute façon il faut choisir
un angle pour s'arrêter stéphane est
bien ici je crois que c'est clair que
les noirs déjà n'ont plus aucun problème
mais bien la paire de fou une fois que
six très fort ces gens là quatre ans
prises au lille va être pris ce plan
c'est sûr par le foot 17 ou par la dame
qui est attaquée ou par la dame qui peut
descendre la tour en 1 8es très fort du
haut rhin pion à passer avec une tour
derrière c'est toujours intéressant tout
à fait donc ici de toute façon ce qu'il
faut voir c'est que l'activité des noirs
est forte
2 les blancs pas d' attaque et 3 la
structure d'options des blanches est
affaibli donc tout simplement il n'y a
pas eu vraiment de compensation pour le
sacrifice de pions donc on vous remontre
depuis le début ce qui s'est passé après
j'en prends un f4 fou pour un f4 demba
cissé cheikh rouhou h1n1 prend b2 b5 bi
le sacrifice attaque le quai et c3 il
faut aller en des cinq cavaliers
préemption prendre et là il faut
échanger les pièces en jeu donc qu'elle
et ses 5 menace où j'ai 80 à skype en
foot est roi
avec déjà une position tout à fait
agréable à jouer il suffit de pas se
faire enfermer la dame c'est important
suffit d'aller échanger les pièces et de
rendre le pion des types de données dans
des conditions qui seront avantageux
voilà donc comment contrer sa fille
une nouvelle partie c'est la partie
freyssinet rôle anges voilà j'ai deux
parties donc championnat de france je
crois à 96 amérique d'elle donc laurent
frayssinet le jeune aux dents longues
ouais à l'époque ne savait pas très bien
que je contrôle un acheteur donc ils
jouaient cette variante avec f4 ouais il
voulait la jouer solid 2 5i donc que 5
kg vif trois quais les bd celle des 7 à
4 normal fawcett four détroit petit rock
petit rock tu en prends un f4 et l'a
donc la voir la partie combien de voir
il ya eu foule point f4 voilà ce qui
permet donc d'un v6 échec alors là les
blancs par le coût principal de cette
position se débarrasse de tous les
problèmes sur cette diagonale en jouant
le courroux h relâche
voilà il fera plus d'échec il ya plus
d'échecs maintenant évidemment ils
veulent reprendre le pion ouais donc il
faut le défendre
cavani ashton ouais ou jouer aux dames
b6 pour empêcher la zone brzeska c'est
pas tout à fait là d'un des six lauréats
à 5 peut-être exhaler canadien avec un
gain de temps très fort gagne un temps
sur la dame madame sais pas où aller oui
parce que s'il vient au bk très bien
voire risquer de se faire enfermer alors
il aura quatre à quatre ça va pas du
tout ouais donc ici il faut jouer quel
gâchis pour défendre ses pions voilà ce
que si les blues reprennent ils vont
être mieux donc ça ressemble un peu un
gambit du roi un petit peu d'anti
comprend le pion et on défend voilier on
le défend avec le cavalier tout à fait
deux grands coups dans cette variante
qu'on va regarder rapidement il ya le
cook avait lieu un écailler des caps qui
ont tous les deux des avantages et
inconvénients différents le coût de
chevalier est intéressant puisqu'il
permet de récupérer le tueront vent fou
à 2 et cavaliers detroit après pour les
reprendre le club cap - et le coup
qu'ils avaient des quatre c'est celui de
la partie on va le voir tout de suite
qu'il ne le coup de frais si le coût de
facile freyssinet rouge g6 on défend le
quadrillage s'en fout d'eux donc
l'amener à ce fou prend 5 avec un
désastre désastre complet c'est à dire
qu'on
déjà les blancs récupérer pion à près
d'un projet sainte way et la structure
de pions noirs seraient totalement
affaibli laurent et noir seraient
faibles c'est inadmissible
donc il faut absolument jouer le coup
voilà cavaliers 6 donc les deux
cavaliers se protègent à noter qu'avec
une structure comme ça il n'y a jamais
de g4 pour attaquer le cavaliere 5
puisqu'il a toujours pu engranger trois
la prise en face à la fin mais il a
toujours la prise en passant pas
délicate ici laurent frayssinet joue la
variante dans l'esprit c'est fou prend
h5 câbles hypron h5 et cavaliers des
cinq qui va récupérer le cuivre 4 mais
là tout simplement les noirs ont un
moyen extrêmement sûre d'égaliser cette
partie voire même de prendre un petit
avantage
on nous fout g5 on consolide le plus
remarquable pour échanger des pièces
voilà on veut changer les pièces est
arrivé dans la position qui de toute
façon va arriver puisque les blancs
n'ont pas le choix ils doivent reprendre
ce qu'on enlève 4 donc ils prennent on
prend vous prend cavaliers prend un tour
prend ce qu'on appelle un échange
généralisé et maintenant pour bien jouer
cette position est bien il faut un
sortir cette tour et la mettre sur la
colonne eux
ouais 2 donc trouver une case pas trop
bête pour le fou pour faire ça ouais
pareil pour la dame est ensuite au bon
moment jouer des six des 5es changement
les pions et le fou sera supérieure aux
cavaliers donc c'est ce qui a suivi dans
la partie est ce qu'on va voir
rapidement d'un v6 attaque le pied au b2
effectivement un petit au passage un
petit coup sur la jambe et 2b 3 fou 17
on voit un jeu extrêmement simple encore
le projet fou le lave vaisselle de la
semaine case parental intéressante parce
que
elles contrôlent toutes les cases du
cavalier qui sont déjà contrôlés par des
pions alors là on peut se poser la
question stéphane toujours est-ce que
c'est fou qui domine le cavalier ou une
équipe de fous moi elle est toujours un
petit peu entendu c'est toujours
difficile délicat
en tout cas ici fu 17 c'est un coup tout
simplement vous sortir le fou pour m la
tour sur la colonne dam des trois tours
à huit tours à f1 nancy n'est essayons
de faire pression sur kiev cette équipe
a vraiment faible qui est bien protégé
qui est bien protégé tours 7
donc là ça y est on va on veut doubler
sur la colonne eux est attaqué puis en
tout cas tout simplement tout à fait et
les blancs dans sa position dans tout
simplement plus plan à leur disposition
ils ne savent plus quoi faire donc
lampre ci n'a joué tour et six dames c5
et d'un médecin qu'on améliore encore la
position de nos pièces ont effectivement
il est revenu dans cette position il
sait plus quoi faire et maintenant des
six des 5 qui arrive avec égalisation
complète des noirs voire même un léger
avantage puisque on voit que les tours
sont mieux placés que les tours blanches
donc ce coup stéphane on va le revoir
puisque on s'intéresse principalement à
l'ouverture la pression pro f 4 roues h
15 à 10 h 5
le couple laurent frayssinet le choix de
laurent frayssinet qu'avec des quatre
n'est pas très dangereux
ouais pour ça hein on défend le cavalier
hi5 avec l'option on joue chez six là
les blancs attaques locales 10h un
qu'avec fraudes ont leur défend et
qu'edf 6 pour reprendre ceux qui ont
acheté à très bien y'a pas d'autres
choix il faut prendre 1 h 5 cavaliers
prend écailles des cinq mois là pour
attaquer deux fois avec le cavalier le
fou le point 4 et maintenant on élimine
notre mauvaise ou le fou aux sept ans
jean foucher 5 échange généralisé en f4
et là c'est gagné
vous n'avez plus qu'à sortir votre tour
les 617 tour but donc c'est pas très
très dangereux maintenant on arrive à la
pression la plus dangereuse
c'est la dernière le choix de christian
bauer entre boris belles chambres
donc on va voir tout de suite les
premiers coups qui sont une fois de plus
les mêmes ne joue pas contre n'importe
qui et plus bauer la joute entreprises
qu'elles forment donc pas forcément une
partie facile mais avec ce choix f4 il
espère avoir une position solide petit
rock tu reprends avec 4,3 à shanghai h
et maintenant cavalier e pas parler que
kennedy 4 un peu différent alors ici une
petite astuce qui est très bien c'est le
couple qui avait lieu de cinq
alors lequel dit ajoutant qu'ils avaient
l'air emprise stefan wey donc il faut
regarder ce qui se passe quand même si
on comprend bien si il ya le petit piège
fou j'ai quatre fous g4 et jean ping the
queen et way the queen a plus de cases
la dame est enfermée elle ne peut pas
prendre le fou cause du cavalier et
toutes les autres cas sont contrôlées
par des pièces voilà le fou contrôler la
se fout la contrôler
là et là se fout là contrôle ici et les
pions contrôle le reste
la dame n'a plus de gaz donc ici on peut
jouer le coup cavaliers ou cinq cas un
bon coup puisque puisque le cavaly bien
placés ici tout simplement et en plus ça
défend indirectement que alliage 15
pouces 2 on arrive à leur logique
maintenant que le feu est parti en deux
cas on n'a plus aucune raison eh bien ce
sont désorganisés on revient à 9,6 alors
on a perdu de temps mais en a mille
cavaliers en scène qu'est ce qu'on avait
dit qu'être un plan b pour intéressant
dans cette danse est parti puisque
maintenant après fou prend 1,4 on joue
au cices et là on a notre position rêvée
de la chef d'un gang stéphane vu avec
toutes les pièces bien placé on vous
montre la suite de la partie rapidement
mais déjà à partir d'ici si vous avez un
bon feeling dans la cécilienne cette
position ne doit pas vous faire peur on
regarde la suite assez rapidement avant
de conclure cavaliers detroit
cavaillé g6 fou j'ai trois des cinq
coups thématique la poussée libératrice
qui était inévitable fouet f3 l'on peut
prendre quatre avec une nulle immédiate
beauce galfond de choisi de jouer des
quatre pour le gain possible gagner il y
avait beaucoup d'embranchements possible
c'est finalement et finalement la partie
a été nul 13 longueurs ayant serré la
vis donc c'est solide pour les blancs
mais avec les noirs si on joue assez
précis on risque pas de perdre mais on
peut avoir même un peu d'initiative tout
à fait donc là en fait vous n'avez pas
grand chose à craindre
rappelez vous bien de toutes les merdes
qu'on a dit le premier coup c'est fou
ces cartes le choix de pierre les pour
le coup dangereux
là il faudrait damas 5 justement pour
clouer le quai vallet c3 et ensuite
avoir à cazaux 5 pour le cavalier sur
food et 3 quelques principal il faut
penser à prendre un f4 au bon moment
quand les blancs ne peuvent pas
reprendre sinon ils doivent donner le
pion b2 non ça c'est la variante la
deuxième partie que nous avons vu et
après avoir chanté bien il ya deux
variantes à connaître et des quatre
cavaliers
sur quoi vous avez les deux parties qui
sont plus ou moins les parties de
référence c'est freyssinet rolland et
bauer entre golf hand ou les noirs n'ont
jamais eu de problème donc voilà c'est
fini pour cette leçon avec quelque 4
c'est fini pour cette relation avec six
f4 donc on vous remercie d'avoir suivi
l'émission merci stéphane d'études une
fois de plus mais c'est normal
et ce n'est que 11e rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour un diagonale la
leçon toujours sur la défense nador
merci de nous avoir suivis